if you could go back in time and give
yourself one piece of advice before
joining the teams what would that be I
don't know I don't think nothing I
wouldn't do it any differently I liked I
could say I would've did this but I'm
glad I did stuff like as a knucklehead
and had some hard knocks and no I know
no I wouldn't done anything differently
mm-hmm cuz the good the bad stuff that I
went through made me better and a good
side you know that kind of shit but yeah
that's one of those questions too
it's you know this is there's people
that ask
there's a nice there's people that ask
these kind of questions they're looking
for they're looking for like a one like
a one thing I answer of like you know if
you could tell yourself here's another
cool if you if you go back and tell
yourself you're 20 year old self what
would you tell yourself like it's or oh
yeah yeah invest in you know what is it
Apple Apple or whatever oh yeah what's
the one leadership lesson you like
there's always that kind of thing
or they ask it about everything man like
that people ask it about everything
what's the one book you would what's in
a they ask the same kind of question
that there's never an answer
yeah I mean it's like when I figured out
early on is like okay you know what book
cool about face somebody asked me yeah
that somebody somebody asked me that in
the live podcast and and like I talk
about I've been talking about about face
since I started talking to cat cora's
public yeah is awesome and so this guy
at the wife podcasts in New York some
professors if you could recommend one
book and I'm like does anyone only
yesterday every was a cop-out face guy
was not in the game right asking that
question or you could easily say like
remember like
cracked magazine it was about the same
yeah so it's weird I'm not trying it you
know it's like people want to hear they
want the information to be so distilled
down but it's kind of like this kind of
gotta do the work yeah it's kind of like
being in jujitsu and being like well
what's the one move you should know in
jujitsu it's like mmm you know there
actually is not one move so asking Tony
what the one piece of advice it's like
man like where what is that where do you
stick to your guns probably is good yeah
don't don't give up when you know don't
like get away from your weight and I
want to say principles I hate that word
but you know whatever you believe you're
like the team's like for me I was like
now you know we know we you know you
don't do this you don't do that like if
I'm running a crew and everybody wants
make more time off and then you kind of
give in now now here's what I can do and
that's it if you stick to that and
there's you can't blow up you know
disarm a bomb that already went off mmm
so just stick to what you're doing
unless it's so fucked
duh of course but you know I had this my
my second platoon commander the real
squared away guy but we we did a hydro
at Camp Pendleton and like we went on
that beat it was a freaking nightmare it
was freezing our rooms were huge we go
out we do it it's frogmen is it and then
we we get everything recovered we come
back we sit there in the zodiac typing
up the freakin message with the little
codes in it for how the beaches we come
back we get in we draw them you know the
cartographer guys don't take all that
information and draw the maps and blah
blah blah blah and we and then the
Marines launch we we land the Marines
yeah yeah and then the Marines weren't
happy with what they did they weren't
happy with the landing so I think I'll
reload so the next night they're like
okay we you guys going to go do that
we're doing the whole thing again ruin
everything again yeah so Hydra recon so
we go out and all of us boys
were like you know we just did died or
you know nothing's changed there's
nothing changed and that boss that oh I
see he goes that's not the point he goes
he goes I remember it clear as day
because I'll never forget him saying
this because I use this quote about a
million times with all my guys he goes
you're right he goes hey guys you know
we don't have to do the hydro again but
would that be the right thing to do yeah
you got and I was like get your lead
lines boys I mean that's how I ain't
your biggest is the guy in the mirror
that's the one you got an answer to not
anyone else guy in the mirror yeah that
that like I never forgot that from then
on from the rest of my life it's been
like what's the actual right thing to do
right now yeah what's the actual right
thing it's usually the one that's so
fucked up in the hottest way up yeah
it's gonna suck yeah it's like
everything yeah well I could do this or
I could do that know which one's hotter
yeah well then that's the one and a
problem should do you and then nine
times out of ten you're gonna be right
yeah yeah
does this suck this Way's easy but this
way sucks okay but that's the one I have
to do yeah because then you if not
you're just like I should've did this
but I'm just all weak and stupid and
then you just get all mad and you end up
doing that anyway so mother just do it
and get it over with